Lauren bobert calls Marjorie Taylor  Greene unhinged in the latest escalation  of this MaGa on Maga violence now I want  to remind you there are people  responding to this saying oh it's a cat  fight it's a cat fight it's a mildly  misogynistic response uh the more  interesting story by the way though is  not a catfight story it's that it used  to be  pro-trump and anti-trump Republicans  the anti-trump Republicans are still  there pro-trump has now split into I  don't even know what to call it unhinged  and more unhinged or unhinged and  slightly less unhinged and it is very  interesting to see Marjorie Taylor green  try to rewrite Her Image to now be cozy  with power and Kevin McCarthy now that  Republicans have taken control of the  house where is Lauren bobert or bobert  as a rokana refers to her congresswoman  Beau bear which I don't even know if  he's doing as a joke or not it doesn't  matter I love it bobert is choosing to  stay on the more extremist side